Conquer,
representing mankind's ability to
overcome
this is the means to fight your fears,
to begin your journey,
the journey into the unknown,
the journey to reach this bold word,
the journey that'll get you lost along
the way.
You will find yourself in the dark,
struggling alone,
but these are the tests that the
universe will place in front of you to
see how strong your desire really is.
Their destiny will never be reached if
you don't depart,
you must never stopped.
Understand the work.
Concrete does not voluntarily admit the
obstacles that are to come,
but simply allows you to chance to greet
them yourself.
You will feel as though you are blindly
running through life,
but asked you to close your eyes and
trust your mind.
Trust your body,
trust her spirit,
trust you.
Your future is simply a vision of the
paradise you have created in your mind.
You must venture into the unknown with
the acceptance that everything you go
through,
we'll have a purpose.
Purpose,
to learn,
purpose,
to change,
a purpose,
to create.
You see,
we're all here on this planet for a
specific reason.
We must find it.
Define it and never stopped believing in
our destiny because life has no meaning
until you create it.
It is the obstacle that we overcome that
grant us the true beauty and life,
the beauty that confirms that everything
that you have ever struggled for,
it was worth it.
If you find trust in your faith and what
the universe has for you,
you will find what you have always been
looking for
because life is not about the
destination.
It's about the journey.